hi I'm Vincent D'Onofrio these are my
five favorite films Midnight Cowboy I
think it's a perfect movie the actors in
it because of the way it was shot
because of the kind of stock of film
they used because of the way New York
City was when they shot it other than
theatre I've never seen it was the first
film I saw with her that didn't have a
comfortable story to it didn't have a
happy ending didn't have things that
don't challenge you I mean that cowboy
was all those things for me husbands
which is a John Cassavetes stone that's
the one that shows you his style of
shooting and performing and acting in
the most clear simple way to see these
men older than me brave enough to
humiliate themselves and and expose
themselves in the most kind of
disgusting and pathetic ways as men and
as a young man I found that enlightening
the Great Dictator which is a Chaplin
film there are speeches in that movie
that will always be around they'll never
go away we're always gonna know what
they were we don't want to hate and
despise one another in this world is
room for everyone and the good earth is
rich but we have lost the way you could
see him change the industry you could
see an independent film can be as moving
and as big as the big studio Colossus
monsters with chariot races and the
whole bit
Fantasia I saw when my childhood I saw
Fantasia twice and then I saw it again
as a teenager smoking dope and I thought
this is the best [ __ ] movie ever made
that your imagination is endless and
that that storytelling can take any
shape and so when it comes to animation
I think that Fantasia took it really
really far it made me understand and I
think it made a lot of people probably
understand in the film business to how
far you can really go a brilliant film
that's called Man Bites Dog it was the
first time since Godard they shot it in
the conventional way but dropping the
fourth wall if you lose that and you let
the camera enter the actual drama it's
extraordinary because the guy who plays
the lead in it is
he's so intriguing and so scary at the
same time that you you want to be his
friend as long as you have a gun at all
times I was still just completely drawn
in until the black eye said until the
very enemy just kept pulling me along
and kept me on the edge of my seat so
that's that's the last
[Music]